Catrina here yes I am with your address
sure I'll try to do it justice so I'll
just go through a number of issues that
were raised so first of all that all of
a sudden were in this context of contact
tracing we're collecting new types of
data that we were not necessarily
collecting before thinking about in this
way we need to be aware of that we have
new sets of issues that are going to
come up because of that we should be
keeping in mind that any changes that
happen either in the software on your
phone or in terms of social norms and
expectations that happen in this context
of kovat are likely to persist and so we
should be aware that we're unlikely to
be able to make sort of temporary
changes what we've seen in the
deployment and the tech side is you know
exciting on the one hand you know very
quickly technologists have sort of
rushed to put together all sorts of
interesting solutions and there has been
more discussion of privacy issues and we
might have feared there there would have
been at the same time the sort of
modeling of the threats and the risks
involved these deployments has been far
from rigorous or thorough and that's
really concerning because we are like I
said collecting new data new risks and
nobody's really exposing in some
rigorous way what are the trade-offs
what are the harms what is being
protected against what is not being
protected against so that societies can
make reasonable decisions this can't be
I here's the problem
technology is the solution this has to
be technology enables the following
trade-offs we need to put that into
discussion with other tools such as
those from law and policy to try to
decide what are they appropriate
trade-offs to make and there was
discussion of the importance in these
times of public trust and social soft
solidarity and concerns
the deployment of widespread
surveillance or tracking or poor
deployment thereof can be really harmful
to these really really crucial tools for
governments I to fight the virus and
there's concern that focusing
specifically on contact tracing when
it's only one part of a broader system
may be somewhat misplaced we saw sort of
a brief summary of the Israeli context
which is interesting in that we have
some simultaneous deployment of two
different types of technologies for
doing contract tracing one of them sort
of a very heavy government surveillance
not optional the other an optional
somewhat privacy oriented I am also
released by the government but by a
different branch of the government the
confusing messaging and difficulties in
having sort of these two coexist and
Deirdre used a phrase that I liked a lot
I don't know who to credit and I'd love
to know um she described this these
deployments as pre public health
applications sort of I'm using analogy
to pre crimes with this idea that we're
we're preemptively doing this this
gathering um we haven't really thought
through what that means and what the
consequences are um we reencounter the
question that came up earlier in the
talks of privacy from whom as being
crucial and a recurring theme in the
discussion was the importance of making
the trade-offs more transparent and more
carefully analyzed so that that we can
really make good choices out there I'm
sure I missed important pics great thank
you
these are really important points one of
the barriers for making this more
transparent is the fact that a lot of
this data is being called this data in
fact is being collected on private
infrastructure
now being governed by the API of the
smartphone's and we've discussed this in
team two that talked about the
public-private interface and the way in
which Google and Apple said the norms in
their API about what any data could be
collected in how it is to be used and
Shafi will use it so I be a lot shorter
because I think I got is no supplement
me so we talked about the public versus
private we highlighted talked and
highlighted the fact that Google and
apples have control the scene here
because they make the rules and their
rules where that whatever they
information is obtained through their
API cannot be used in a variety of ways
by other let's say apps and there's
there's very strict list of rules it's
or forbids you to use it for aggregation
and or in other in other ways where it's
pretty clear that it would be very
useful even as a user if you opted in
and you had information about well that
you were let's say that you were where
you were you might volunteer that
information for public health benefit
but this is the I think the from what I
understood is that it's very hard to
work together with Google and Apple it
to get you know more benefit out of just
being notified that you were close to
someone within the past 14 days who may
have been just a positive and the issue
with that is first of all is that they
have control and so in principle that's
uh that's something that's problematic
but we've also come up with this
question of whether this gives them an
unfair advantage in the market and they
came up this issue there's competition
law and this it's them really unfair
advantages in terms of their competition
with other companies and that's also
because this app is expected to be use
cross-border that's another aspect in
which they can control the market more
now not only do they have unfair
advantage within let's say maybe the US
but also cross border because it's gonna
be used more widely that way so that's
quite interesting in terms of what's
something that if it you know
orders Lauda governs that therefore you
know the fairness of their market market
chair another things a provocative thing
that norm brought up was to say that you
know what we it's an interesting case
here to contrast what's happening
between the west and the east east
meaning China and so forth where they
can actually figure out exactly where
you're at what you should do you get
some kind of announcement on your phone
telling you Kenny law you know get on
the subway or not which it seems to be
actually quite relevant to controlling
the pandemic whereas we are trying to
use this private in public and and be
careful and adhere to the fact that
maybe Apple and Google don't want to be
to destroy their market credibility and
so forth and their and therefore their
the amount of information you can get is
very limited and can so the
controversial question is can the West
in our democracy really match what can
be done in a time like this
it's a challenge in ability and those
might be suitable to specific countries
but might be social and legal norms
maybe one thing that is very clear is
that for example in Israel the location
history of commitment impatient is
something that is published
it published in newspapers and several
website and telecom channels so try to
say it's very important to hide the
location of copywriting positive people
or persons is something that it doesn't
really make sense in the specific legal
and social norms in Israel and this
something that has a price to explain
ability and insecurity when we try to
implement the protocol and this one
science we tour the world the solution
is a fee that might raise many
difficulties and Google happen and will
not negotiate with anyone and when they
control the market they not they do not
allow people to actually thank you this
is of course this of course relates to
differently the possibility of different
interpretations of privacy depending on
the country the needs and the culture
maybe and again once it is designed by
the API there is no room for
experimentation and varieties and
developing these different concept it
also has to do with trust right one of
the issues that we discuss is whether
you trust the government and you need
the companies to protect you against the
government or whether you trust the
companies right and that leads us to the
third team that we had talking about
mandatory apps and voluntary apps and I
think Orin was moderating this yeah so
again I'll try to do justice although
I'm sure I will fail so I'll focus on my
own takeaways from this very interesting
session so the first thing that you know
I learned is that voluntary versus
mandatory is a false dichotomy in fact
the
name any difference there's a range of
mechanisms on this spectrum and you know
they start from voluntary when we just
tried to convince people to internalize
a certain set of norms of what they
should be doing and what they should not
be doing then there are various types of
choice architecture or nudge type
interventions and then there are
mandatory rules that we might put in
place and basically the kind of set of
sanctions or incentives that we could
design again can you know range from
very weak so very strong and we have a
very large spectrum of possibilities and
so when we take this from the from you
vials and legal order behavioral ethics
perspective to the economics of CS that
we colony bother teaching us about then
we will might call the same thing or we
might talk about mechanism design or
design up the rules the rules of the
game and the legal rules of the game and
their various options of Hollywood's be
designing these rules again thinking
about kind of incentives and carrots and
sticks and internalization and
understanding that if we have you know
too strong an incentive it might cloud
out kind of the internal motivations of
various types of actors to want to
comply the the norm the legal norm of
the ethical norm there is a force large
empirical questions that we need to
figure out in terms of what kind of
populations we are dealing with Eva
mentioned before them you have different
people in different countries and issues
of trust some people will just do what
is right if we tell them and explain why
this is the right thing to do other
people need stronger incentives how do
we come balance these two things
together the mechanism design literature
that we have learned about and talked
about focuses on questions of lying and
cheating and how can we design the
mechanism in the way that people will
not lie and cheat think so one example
was we're talking about contact tracing
concern is even if we mandate when these
mandatory applications or even like that
is really Secret Service or shabak doing
this for us
people might leave their phones at home
now for me personally this seems
and unthinkable to leave my phone at
home I understand some people do this
and so again how do we decide how do we
design the system to make sure that
people don't do this again from a
general enforcement perspective take
your phone with you whenever you go out
of the house is a rule like any other
rule we can think about the ways to
enforce this if we think that is the
right rule to have so so this was one
set of issues that we discussed and it
has to do with another range of options
and mechanisms and legal regimes that we
can think about the other thing that we
touched about albeit briefly is now that
we know the range of possibilities we
don't know yeah let's say no the range
of possibilities help me choose between
them on the spectrum between voluntary
and mandatory and everything in between
and the idea is that we need to think
very hard about our objective function
and how do we quantify the cost of
privacy and compare this in the general
cost-benefit analysis to the cost and
benefits in terms of morbidity or
mortality ways that we might be benefits
reduce mortality and morbidity that we
might get kind of a stronger more on the
mandatory side of the spectrum as
compared to the voluntary side so those
are at least for me the main takeaways
great thank you
our last team was discussing issues
related to transparency and
accountability which are probably one of
the measures for building trust and
encouraging people to voluntarily opt
into a system and here we have Vince yes
hi I actually tried to very quickly type
up slides and I'm gonna try to share
those with you now or can you see them
yeah okay good so we had two wonderful
talks by let me try to move this over
here you can still see it yes just put
it on display display can you see it
okay so we had two wonderful invited
talks by Professor Kennedy from bu
computer science and professor Stromberg
from NYU Law Cathy and so we'll start
with Cathy's talk and she emphasized
that well when we think about
transparency generally often when you
think about algorithms in AI that are a
little bit more difficult to understand
whereas here these kind of apps at least
it's pretty clear what they're supposed
to do maybe it's not understandable by
everyone but at least we can get a
pretty good handle on it and so in that
sense it's different
also maybe we're not quite as worried
about public health authorities having
incentives to do things that they
shouldn't be doing as we might be with
some other private companies so we'll
get back to that in a second but
participation is a key worry because
it's very hard to coerce people at least
in in our societies to participate in
these things and so that's going to
probably be the main issue and we need
trusts for people to be willing to
participate and a good starting point
might be - compared to traditional
contact tracing and what are we worried
about there we mostly worry about
information leakage there various kinds
of information that you might be
concerned about it leaking and who is
going to get this information so
traditionally in the traditional set up
the public health authorities and maybe
researchers would get it and there you
might still worry about some kind of
mission creep that they want to do more
with this data than they were supposed
to yeah in the digital world there are
various new issues that come up so first
of all we have new entities involved
such as the smartphone companies and the
app designers that traditionally don't
play a role in the contact tracing and
there are new kinds of data that's
appears well an interesting point that
Kathy made was that normally in the
traditional world sometimes there's some
retroactive filtering of data that they
decide that some data maybe shouldn't be
in there after all which you might have
other concerns about but now that's no
longer a possibility so that's going to
have some effect potentially and there's
also the potential for new kinds of
mission creeps because the holders of
the data are now different have
different incentives
and in addition to that there's maybe an
emission creep of the technology itself
that it can be expanded that's a new
purposes that maybe we wouldn't have
expected so Kathy's conclusion overall
was that we're doing we should be
worrying about much more than we
typically do when we just think about
privacy preservation then run talked for
a little while and so he mentioned this
issue that well we have to trade off
various basic values here between
individualism social responsibility
centralization and decentralization many
other things and we would like this
discussion to be driven by what is
technically possible but when we think
about what's technically possible as a
computer scientist maybe the first thing
we think about is well here are various
tools from multi-part and multi-party
computation and cryptography more
generally that in theory solve all these
problems and so we're done but it's not
quite that simple in practice again
because we need this trust if people are
not willing to buy into it it doesn't
matter that it has all the properties
that's we would like it to have so a run
was very positive about the GA mechanism
in that it's simple there are no secret
databases or seemed to be no options for
clandestine use and maybe it's even a
model for future intervention in other
kinds of settings but then we had some
questions that maybe were skeptical
about some of these aspects so Elliott's
worried about there still being a
possibility to match identities in
reality and well in security there's
always this concern that there's some
and a strange way around the protections
that we hadn't thought of before so it's
hard to say that every anything is ever
fully secure but at least this kind of
matching would seem to be difficult to
scale to very large numbers of people
voluntary participation whether that's
feasible is is still a big question
there's also the issue that it's not
necessarily the same for everyone right
I think what we heard before that maybe
the Academy between mandatory and
voluntary is a false one and I we
touched on that a little bit as well
that's you know maybe it's not that
voluntary if you work in a big warehouse
and
need to be compliant and they can push
you to to participate in all this Kiera
I mentioned that's well maybe the model
that these apps are being built on is a
little bit outdated now it's based on
this idea that you're within six feet of
each other but that now doesn't seem to
be necessarily the only determinant it's
maybe more important whether people wear
masks if you're inside if there's mental
ation can we get that in and the
response to that well mostly that's not
going to be in there so it's not going
to be the best possible thing that we
could ever have
but maybe it's still helpful in many
ways in particular in finding super
spreaders and so we try to just do the
best we can and then we had several
questions about the role of law and the
role of institutions do we need new
institutions do we need new laws I think
Kathy was leaning towards this being
let's keep this to be a special purpose
application so that you know we don't
want to necessarily cover all this with
general laws this seems to be pretty
specific to public health and maybe
that's how we should be thinking about
it also in terms of the governing
institutions but of course there is a
question whether we really can keep it
that separate from other kinds of
application as well and that's all we
have great excellent Wow this has been a
really rich discussion in the in the
rooms and I think I think for all of us
is just a teaser for the type of
discussion that we could have had on
each of these topics for for a whole
session but unfortunately we're now
gonna have to take a break of ten
minutes we're coming back at 11:30 for
our concluding keynote of the day in the
discussion so we'll hear from have Arian
and from Hal Gaal so please come back at
11:30 those of you who wish to chat we
can stay you know during the break if
you don't need the ten minutes you will
you're welcome to stay